I think what we're seeing right now is people are going to college,...
...they're spending 200,000 dollars on an education for four years...
...and leaving without practical skills that they can apply immediately for a job opportunity.
Those people may need something that will give them what they need to find employment.
I'm Zach Sims.
I'm the co-founder of a company called Codecademy,...
...and we teach people to program online.
My name is Ryan, I'm the technical co-founder of Codecademy.
Programming or code in general is something that isn't immediately accessible to a lot of people.
They're either not really comfortable with it or they don't know where to begin...
...so we're trying to make getting started as easy as possible...
...and actually strike the imagination by showing them magic.
You can show them what a program is capable of before you have to explain it.
We start you off by typing your name in, right?
And then we walk you through, like, how to do addition in a terminal,...
...how you can write a program to do really simple things like that.
We explain, like, what the language is, why you need to learn it on.
It's really simple for people that have never done something before.